[Musique]
elle
e
[Musique]
à l'autre docteure arlene c'est moi
albert albert de salvo et bien si je
m'attendais à voir de vos nouvelles
comment ça va pour vous
et bien en fait plutôt pas mal walpole
n'est pas si terrible que ça finalement
je me suis fait mon petit trou j'en suis
ravi pour vous albert et ça me fait bien
plaisir de vous entendre seulement
pourquoi pourquoi m'appeler moi il y à
quelque chose dont j'ai besoin de parler
il ya de très bon psychiatre à hualpen
là c'est différent
ce que je veux c'est dire la vérité au
sujet de l'étrangleur de boston
la vérité
d'accord vous avez fait le bon choix
mais on ne peut pas parler de ça au
téléphone je vais faire en sorte qu'on
puisse se voir demain à 9 heures dans
une salle de thérapie privé là on pourra
parler ouais ce sera super bien merci de
te remercie du fond du coeur
où
[Musique]
il te plait faut vraiment que je bois je
me chauffe rythme pas mais c'est comme
ça je te laisse montrer plus partie
du billet par roméo ce n'est pas digne
de votre rang
je vais donc enfourché mon destrier
regagner mon château de camelot seul
dans cette nuit ténébreuse et classés
gentes dames jouent low s'agit
et
[Musique]
si j'avais besoin de soins demande à
merlin il fera ça mieux que moi
[Musique]
où
oh
on
[Musique]
mais
madame jennifer foster
[Musique]
madame jennifer mitchum foster
non trop de rallonge
jennyfer foster
jane foster
madame jennifer foster
non mais quelle cruche
toi système
comment est ce possible capitaine
comme un descriptif aussi détaillée des
meurtres de l'étrangleur at il pu se
retrouver à la une de la presse ce truc
est un véritable manuel pour tous les
meurtriers de boston et bien c'est ma
faute
j'ai laissé des informations sortir
je suis désolé jack
seulement ceux d'en haut me met une
pression d'enfer pour qu'on règle ce
dossier au plus vite une fille nous
menacent constamment d'un remaniement et
pas seulement de notre service il en a
après tout les services du comté alors
au point où on en est je me suis dit que
ça pourrait nous aider seulement c'est
tout le contraire ça va surtout
compromettre mon enquête mais quelle
enquête job on n'a pas un seul point de
départ dans ce dossier aucun témoin
aucune repartons que la dispo qu'une
sorte que dalle
capitaine le témoin est en bas on vous
attend pour commencer l'identification
[Musique]
mon
non
[Musique]
ans
j'aimerais que ça aille vite n'ayez pas
peur il n'y a aucun risque
[Musique]
ils ne peuvent pas vous voir oui j'ai
bien compris
[Musique]
prenez tout votre temps
le rigolo avec les lunettes
c'est albert de salvo
il ya deux ans de ça il a été arrêté
pour agression sexuelle il a fait 18
mois à middlesex avant de sortir en
conditionnelle
et celui du coup là le grand lui c'est
frank addario le casier qu'il se
trimballe je suis assez surpris quand
les trouver en liberté oui c'est lui je
ne reconnais que c'est bien lui c'est
lui au bout de la file à droite c'est
bien son visage c'est bien lui
[Musique]
vous êtes sûr de films attraper
il m'a attrapée cogner sur la tête alors
croyez moi je suis pas prête d'oublier
son visage c'est le même que dans mes
cauchemars chaque thé l'intérieur mettez
le dans un trou et qu'il y assez terne
compagne la toile un jour je te
retrouverai 12 ans 6 elle est en jeu
mais l'avocat
bon vous allez vous asseoir
remplir ces formulaires et ce sera
terminé et si on sait pas lire on fait
quoi et bien si vous faut de l'aide on
va vous trouver un assistant j'aimerais
autant que ce soit vous ça je m'en
serais douté
qu'est-ce qui a le pingouin
rien moi ce pingouin bien raide et bien
coincé dans son costard de merde ceux
des smokings normalement tadic a
normalement la blague du pingouin c'est
un truc qu'on dit sur les gens se patine
l ai dit non tu me prends pour un débile
je sais très bien ce que je dis c'est
une tournure de style ok encore d'accord
je disais ça comme ça
faut pas me chercher j'ai l'estomac qui
me brûle tu vois des fois quand on dit
ça pète
mais toi je t'ai bien on parle pas aux
prisonniers compris aller avant ce
[Musique]
qu'est ce t'as tout s'arrête pas en
jetant chariots et vous n'avez pas
tranche manquent pas dans les catégories
peut-être mais vous devez quand même
mais quelque chose eh ben je vais
m'expliquer ça chez moi passe
[Musique]
oh
mon
m
[Musique]
salut marib est
au seuil et vous êtes rentrée comment ça
va excellent
bonjour belle journée n'est ce pas ah
oui hein je voulais vous dire j'ai un
nouveau bureau sur le campus on se
connaît eh bien on s'est souvent croisés
je comptais vous en parler mais j'étais
débordé à lagence une agence oui en ce
moment ça tourne bien depuis que jackie
est à la maison blanche on me demande
constamment de trouver des filles qui
lui ressemble vous voulez dire que vous
travaillez dans la main d' ouais on peut
dire ça je suis chercheur de perles
commença chercheurs de père c'est du
jargon en fait je suis le gars qui
repère les futurs mannequins chez les
mesures je les prends en photo et je
vais rencarde avec la chanson ça doit
être passionnant
en fait ça pourrait être pas mal que je
prenne vos mesures vous me semblez assez
bien correspondre à ce que cherche la
chance vous fait quoi comme taille merci
c'est très gentil je fais du 38 non vous
ne ferez pas croire ça vous fait pas du
38 mais si si si je vous assure qu il
faut que j'y aille
à temps des
mesures et moi et vous verrez que j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut tout ce qu'il faut
pour être mannequin oui d'accord mais
c'est quand même un business sans pitié
vous vous sentez prête à affronter ça
y'a qu'on essayait au que je pourrais le
savoir une excellente réponse merci
pardonnez moi suzanne et bien susan que
diriez-vous de m'accompagner dans mon
bureau j'ai dit oui
alors en fait je suis pas sûr que ce
soit une très bonne idée je veux dire
venir vous faire mesurer dans le bureau
d'un type que vous connaissez même pas
une autre fois peut-être
attendez on peut très bien faire ça ici
mon studio et juste au dessus mené le
tueur mais oui venez ce sera plus
pratiquement d'accord pourquoi pas mais
essayons de faire s'invite hockey parce
que là c'est plutôt un temps pour être
dehors cinq minutes
vous ne m'avez pas dit comment s'appelle
votre agence hausse et la black and
white management c'est en centre-ville
la prochaine fois je vous donnerai ma
carte et s'il me recrute combien ce que
je serai payé cdu 40 dollars de l'heure
vous êtes sérieux 40 dollars c'est une
très bonne paye avec un salaire pareil
je pourrais rembourser mes études en
même pas une année 40 dollars c'est
juste pour bosser sur boston mais ça
peut être plus il vous envoie à
l'étranger tous frais payés évidemment à
l'étranger c'est monnaie courante on a
pas mal de filles qui font des allers
retours réguliers sur paris quoi pour
les défilés
voilà on y est
m
voilà
vous n'êtes pas gêné non pourquoi il se
rêve
vous faites guide 90 90 je croyais
exposé du 85 non je suis formel vous
faites du 90 et une pour le bonnet
comment vous faites comment vous le
mesurer
et bien en fait il n'existe pas vraiment
d'instruments pour mesurer le bonnet
dans la profession on pratique la
méthode de l'estimation à la main bon si
vous dites après tout c'est vous le
professionnel
pour faire la mesure il va falloir qu'il
y ait un contact de tirer oui j'avais
bien compris
vous avez les matous chubb
bon alors c'est du combien d'après vous
encore un petit instant mais là quand
même vous devriez savoir non
je suis désolé je dirais que vous êtes
entre le sait il des comment vous dites
que vous vous appelez déjà
johnson monsieur johnson mais appelez
moi gary et votre agence ou est ce
qu'elle se trouve c'est quoi l'adresse
exacte et un en centre-ville sur la 76e
aux 83 les numéros du centre ville ont
tous trois chiffres oui c'est le 783
rabon pour être en même si je suis sûr
que vous êtes une bonne étudiante j'ai
pas trop l'impression que vous ayez la
fibre pour ce genre de boulot et moi je
n'ai pas l'impression que vous
travaillez vraiment dans la mode ce qui
veut tout ce qui veut dire que je veux
que vous partiez immédiatement sinon
sinon j'avais tout de suite décroché mon
téléphone et expliquer tout ça la police
mais explique en quoi
la paternelle
s'il ya un truc que l' agence ne
supporte pas c'est bien les grandes
gueules et les filles qui pète de
travers on les renvoie chez elle par le
premier ravi
où est ce que tu crois que tu vas comme
ça j'ai vérifié figure toi y'a aucune
issue
à moins que tu veuilles sauter par la
tête tu veux jouer à la fée clochette
ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai souvent
entendu quand j'étais en garnison en
allemagne sauf que c'était en allemand
john rabe à une libre échange à bobigny
en fait c'étaient des [ __ ]
s'il vous plaît prenez tout
rien je vous promets
tu sais je peux facilement des fonds
c'est cette porte est franchement ce
serait bien plus simple si tu ouvrais
ouvre cette [ __ ] de parts
[Musique]
or cette [ __ ] porte
tu vas ouvrir cette [ __ ] de porte
o o ouvre cette [ __ ] de parts comme
tel
[Applaudissements]
désolé pour le retard mais à cette heure
ci sur la 11e c'est un vrai cauchemar
ouais ouais je connais ça j'ai déjà
monté ouais bien sûr suis là depuis une
heure et sait comment c'est pas un beau
spectacle enfin tu verras ça lui j'adore
ça va ça lui donne le nom c'est sam hans
bevers l'islam ans tout juste 22 ans
bien qu'il ya un colon noué autour de
son cou elle n'a pas été étranglée mais
poignardé à la nuque c'est une nouveauté
l'assassin la laisser la jupe levé et
les cuisses ouvertes histoire que tout
le monde en profite bien sûr barcelone
auriez-vous par hasard d'une oeuvre dans
la sphère de l'étrangleur
ce n'est pas qu'une seule peur il semble
y avoir plusieurs meurtriers et on peut
savoir ce qui vous rend si sûr de sage
qu'est ce qui vous assure qu'il n'y en a
qu'un seul eh bien sans vouloir vous
apprendre votre métier le même modus
operandi l'agression sexuelle l'entrée
par effraction le collant tour de la
corse et caetera et je pourrai encore
continuer vous m'excuserez monsieur
winfield mais c'est loin de me paraît
tout aussi clair les premières victimes
étaient âgées le sixième était jeune et
noir ensuite marie brom et maintenant
des vers l'iss à 27 mai vers les
semaines ce qui a été poignardé pour moi
ce n'est pas le même mode opératoire
john il va falloir qu'on se comprenne
et j'aimerais pouvoir trouver des termes
suffisamment clair pour que ça rentre
enfin dans votre crâne
l'année prochaine je serai en course
pour le sénat est la dernière chose dont
j'ai besoin ou encore que d'un meurtrier
sexuelle dans mary c'est une rumeur à la
con qui prétendrait qu'il y en a
plusieurs la position officielle c'est
qu'il n'ya qu'un meurtrier un seul
est ce que je veux c'est qu'on arrête ce
meurtrier et qu'on en voie d'être aussi
profond que le diable lui même ne
retrouvera puis sa trace est ce que je
veux c'est que ma vie puisse à nouveau
dormir sur ses deux oreilles vous
comprenez sac vous pouvez avoir la
position que vous voulez mais vous
n'avez aucune autorité sur mon
département est monté partement va
continuer à chercher plusieurs tueurs
essayé de me provoquer
je ne travaille pas pour vous mais pour
les gens de cette ville
franchement ça m'étonne que vous ayez
tenu si longtemps vous avez sans doute
un nom car tient bien placé
mais vous êtes clairement trop naïve
pour faire ce métier
j'espère que vous m'avez entendu
ah
bonjour madame ruth sheen héros bonjour
albert c'est gentil comment va votre
jolie femme au plutôt bien il faut juste
qu'elle s'adapte c'est gentil de
vendéens une allemande des alliés de
guerre ça ne peut donner que de très
beaux enfants merci madame le ccino
michael et jody sont en effet très beau
mais vous savez la guerre est finie
depuis presque 20 ans et le même si on
est italien moi je me sens d'abord fier
d'être américain c'est bien pour ça que
je ne suis pas rentré dans l'armée de
mussolini dont celle des nazis
d'ailleurs rien sur albert vous êtes un
gentil garçon en ce beau dimanche oui
madame mais vous sortez dehors tout seul
avec ses histoires d'être anglais ron ne
vous en faites pas que j'ai un bon
protecteur et bien béni soit-il passer
une bonne journée vous aussi à terre
claudia
claude yatela
claudia et
claudia michael
mais où est ce que vous êtes
et vous vous cachez ou quoi
claudia michael joo dit
où sont les enfants chez ta mère c'est
quand même dingue que tu t'en souviennes
pas et j'étais à porter des chocolats et
des fleurs
ça ça marchait à munich albert mais là
on est à boston
la romance c'est terminé maintenant
faudrait que tu sois un homme
je suis un homme non albert
qui ne sera vraiment un homme que quand
tu deviendras un père responsable logar
je suis quand même dehors tous les jours
pour amener à manger oui mais le peu
d'argent que tu gagnes tu on claque la
moitié dans les bars et même si ça se
trouve dans les gargotes a put aller dis
pas de conneries j'sais pas si tu te
rends compte qu'avec ce que tu claques
en bière chaque semaine je pourrais
faire manger les gosses matin midi et
soir du lundi au dimanche
bébé s'il te plait je te jure que je
peux faire mieux tu vas voir je te jure
mais quand elle mère
pourquoi je te croirais
j'ai traversé la moitié du monde pour
être avec toi et tout ça pour quoi
pour te voir devenir alcoolique
albert est ce que tu te souviens de la
promesse que tu m'as fait en allemagne
et que tu as aussi fait à mes parents
je te promets
albert
tu fais chier je suis un homme j'ai des
besoins et emma fans bordel qui kaunas
tu me touches plus jamais tu as compris
c'est comme ça que tu réagi quand je me
comporte en homme mais [ __ ] j'ai des
besoins bordel de merde
[Musique]
mon
mais
c'est encore un e différents
vous avez deux sur john certains les
cinq premières fois le nom ait été fait
en rose est là il a d'abord été serré
puis disposer en rosettes
pendant qu'on est là ce gratte et le
cube d'autres femmes se font assassiner
seulement il n'y a rien qu'on puisse y
faire
ça ne dépend que de nous tenez pas c'est
moi une des pinces
merci
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire de sa
l'envoyer au laboratoire ils pourront
peut-être ont tiré quelque chose en
l'observant microscope à
ça je le verrais pas de mon vivra
[Musique]
bon alors
on a quelque chose donc rien du tout à
une seule empreinte digitale dans tout
l'appartement des témoins n'ont aucun
des voisins n'ont rien entendu le
concierge n'était pas là le famille est
prévenu mais c'est fait
je veux savoir si elle s'est récemment
disputés je veux que tous ses amis et
tous les membres de sa famille soient
interrogés
pour fait pas joli petit je suis
retrouvé cette ordure et il paiera pour
ce qu'il t'a fait john l'équipe
médico-légale et là où devrait il lui
libère la place et vous pourriez
retourner au bureau
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] du bureau spinelli
vous savez c'est à cause de cette
attitude qu'on n'arrive pas à attraper
le tueur tout le monde cherche à se
débarrasser du problème à plomb qui la
merde sous le tapis
mais la merde reste là elles
s'accumulent et les meurtres continuent
ce qui est naturel puisque les animaux
s'entretuent et que même en costard
cravate c'est ce que nous sommes des
[ __ ] d'animaux en tant que flic vous
devriez vous demandez où vous en êtes
par rapport à ça
tiens-toi spinelli pourquoi es tu fier
quelle est ta motivation ma motivation
la stabilité de l'emploi la stabilité de
l'emploi à l'époque où mon père était
flic la motivation c'était de lutter
contre le crime et aujourd'hui c'est la
stabilité de l'emploi et j'ai une
famille à nourrir comme tout le monde et
franchement je vais vous dire un truc jo
vous auriez dû devenir maçon vous auriez
touché une bien meilleure et le cas et
john john buchan par les mois encore
comme ça et je vous en terre sous la
paperasse jusqu'à la fin de vos jours
vous comprenez
j'ai été clair
le
médecin
mais l'avenir
[Musique]
vela
used as
[Musique]
la vie
moi
il ya quelqu'un
marc c'est toi chérie
je me souviens pattes avant donner la
clé
marque
chérie
[Musique]
à quoi tu joues mais c'est pas drôle
fait pas oui notamment je te jure que je
tâche la langue compris
j'avais pas l'intention d'être aussi
brutale seulement comme tu résistes je
vais être forcée d'immobiliser tes bras
tu sens que tu sais
les et moi
non mais
j'ai prévu de faire l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si seulement tu avais été sa gêne
chan
[Musique]
une file de la présenter comme la
septième victime de l'étrangleur pour
lui c'est une évidence
le mode opératoire est similaire mais il
ya aussi des différences
marie et lesquelles
et bien elle a été étranglée avec un bar
mais le noeud a été attaché différemment
et à l'imitateur pour les cinq premières
c'était le même gars mais pour se fit
par coeur et 7 filles on a affaire un
copieur qui a tout appris par la presse
tu es un 1er janvier c'est un tueur qui
ne connaît pas les jours fériés elle a
été tuée hier soir ce n'était pas encore
férié mais on l'a trouvée aujourd'hui
une seconde qui est vous qui vous a
laissé entrer au plein milieu de mon
enquête je suis jannah philman du riz
corde le riz corde vous êtes journaliste
je suis surtout l'oeil du public
monsieur mart scène mon devoir et de
l'informer au mieux et au plus vite
c'est bien mais aujourd'hui vous allez
l'informer des hémorroïdes du voisin on
va vous inspecteurs comment est il
possible qu'après un septième meurtre
vous n'ayez toujours ni indice ni
suspect ni piste que savez vous des
pistes quoi vous n'avez pas savoir quoi
que ce soit avant que cette enquête est
atteint sans vous rendez vous manqué de
respect nos sources affirment que vous
n'avez rien du film gladys paraître
demain rue donovan et emmenés là loin
pas seulement dans la pièce d'à côté
d'or
e
[Musique]
chers auditeurs notre ligne sera ouverte
toute la nuit vous attend dans vos
réactions vos témoignages sur ce qu'il
fait en ce moment la une de
l'information à boston les meurtres de
l'étrangère pourquoi la police est elle
incapable d'arrêter ce type comment la
liste des victimes at elle pu devenir
aussi longue la toute première victime
anas les soeurs avaient 50 50 l'assassin
l'a étranglée avec la ceinture de sa
propre province de change c'était le 14
juin 1962 la victime suivante on line à
nichols avait 68 ans elle a été retrouvé
le 30 juin en même temps qu elle n blake
un ballon noué autour du
moment et et aux soirées pas trop mal
mais elle aurait été mieux si tu avais
été là
tu finiras par l'avoir garde la foi
je ne peux pas leur était bien sûr que
tu le peux tu es le meilleur inspecteurs
du comté l'époque je manque de confiance
au moins chéri mais on me demande de
trouver un homme alors qu'il y en a
plusieurs le mode opératoire a beaucoup
changé entre jane sullivan et sophie
parker john avait 67 ans sophie en avait
18 mais elles ont toutes été étranglée
c'était le même cas pour les cinq
premières mais je suis à peu près sûr
que pour lui se terminer et derniers
étaient des imitateurs
les journaux ont publié de véritable
guide pratique surtout les meurtres du
genre suivait ses instructions et vous
passerez pour l'étrangleur ce sentiment
tu en a parlé à quelqu'un une échelle ce
n'est pas qu'un senti pour john nous ne
sommes pas en salle d'interrogatoire
pourquoi être sur la défensive ce n'est
qu'une conversation de coupe ils
perdront chérie je suis un peu ton du ca
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est devenu politique tout le monde
veut qu'il n'y ait qu'un seul homme la
presse république le maire et même
l'attorney général
et pour plaire ce petit monde je suis
sans ce fossé tout une enquête
est bien
tu ne résoudra pas tout ça ce soir en
revanche
si tu me suis tue pour amener sur moi
une enquête approfondie
celui là non je crois vraiment il va
falloir enseigne comme ça ça
comme on va y aller mesdames et
messieurs je vous demande un peu de
silence s'il vous plaît
n'en sait pas beaucoup plus que vous sur
ce qui nous vaut d'être réunis ensemble
mais monsieur winfield ici présent va
sans aucun doute éclairer notre lanterne
bonjour monsieur
j'aimerais que nous nous comportions
tous en professionnel comme vous le
savez l'étrangleur a pu frapper deux
fois dans cette ville sans qu'aucune
piste ne soit établie
je ne doute pas que vous ayez travaillé
dur sur cette affaire mais il faut se
rendre à l'évidence ça ne marche pas et
pendant ce temps je me retrouve sous une
telle pression que je suis sur le point
de chiper par la bouche
j'ai donc mis au point un plan qui
devrait finalement nous donner une
chance de coffrets ce foutu salopards
à partir d'aujourd'hui l'anc est sûre
l'étrangleur sera dirigée par une toute
nouvelle équipe issue de notre
administration
ce nouveau bureau centralisera tout ce
qui concerne l'étrangleur
tous les départements municipaux et je
dis bien tous les départements
seront appelés à collaborer
et à remettre aux bureaux tout ce qui
aura pu être collecté comme preuves ou
comme indice témoignages début de piste
etc
le patron de ce nouveau bureau
et monsieur fred a dit ça
quoi addison et qu'est ce que c'est une
sorte de blague je comprends pas ce
monsieur a dit samedi que s'est t'il de
notre boulot hein
combien de fois at il était sur le
terrain monsieur sans vouloir vous
offenser un bureaucrate ne peut pas
faire le travail d'un policier serge en
donne les vous mettais mon jugement en
doute
est-ce vraiment l'air de plaisanter
mais croyez-moi si cette enquête est
trop drôle pour vous on vous forcera pas
à rester vous pourrez la suivre de votre
cuisine en faisant des cookies vous me
comprenez oui monsieur
vous vous croyez encore à l'école
monsieur smith il n'y aura ni question
nîmes a levé avant que j'ai terminé son
speech
et si pour vous c'est incontrôlable
alors attachez les à votre chaise
également à la tête de ce nouveau bureau
nous aurons l'inspecteur d'état philippe
blot
l'inspecteur john marsden de la police
de boston fera également partie de
l'équipe tout comme andrew tu tenais des
forces de police du massachusetts
ces messieurs seront en permanence
assisté par une batterie d'experts
médicaux venus des quatre coins de
l'état
de plus
la presse va être informés qu'une prime
de 10 mille dollars est prévu pour
quiconque aura des informations pouvant
mener à la capture
de cet assassin
on me regardait tous comme si vous
vouliez me tuer
si vous avez des questions c'est le
moment
ensuite je serais parti
et bien si tout est clair
je vais vous laisser entre de bonnes
mains fred
très chers collègues nous allons tous
devoir faire corps sur ce dossier il va
falloir explorer toutes les possibilités
revoir toutes les informations que nous
avons sur l'étrangleur et nous finirons
par l'avoir d'ailleurs j'aimerais que
nous nous retrouvions ici cet après-midi
disons à partir de 14h30 pour une
première réunion de travail d'ici là
bonne journée
bon eh bien je crois que c'était
suffisamment clair
alors à tout est un peu loin sur alison
écoutez je vais essayer d'arranger ça le
plus vite possible
john il faudrait qu'on ait une petite
conversation
là mon bureau ça ira
désolé non non ça va c'est rien
et voilà le dossier monsieur addison 37
mille pages en touffe bravo bien joué et
richie j'imagine que tout est trié et
dicté selon les spécifications que j'ai
donné oui absolument les gens de
l'informatique ont revu leur copie ils
ont reçu ce matin monsieur
37 mille pages
370 serait déjà été énorme et vous en
avez 37 me eh oui monsieur madeleine ce
document regroupe la totalité des
informations recueillies jusqu'ici c'est
un peu notre bible de plus nous avons la
chance d'avoir avec nous deux brillants
ingénieurs du et mighty qui ont d'ores
et déjà commencé à rentrer ces données
dans leurs ordinateurs des ordinateurs
et pour quoi faire à quoi est-ce qu'ils
servent vos ordinateurs mais à
l'organisation monsieur marsden à
l'organisation monsieur allison il faut
bien plus que des machines et de
l'organisation pour résoudre une affaire
quoi que ce soit qu'il faille pour
résoudre une affaire vous ne l'avez de
toute évidence pas trouvé les gens n'est
résolu d'autres
saloperie de bureaucrates
il paraît que dans un futur proche
l'informatique va nous remplacer
trente sept mille pages
[Musique]
conduit mais d'un autre côté
j'ai déconné je les connais grave c'est
pour ça que je conchie pkoi albert
pourtant voilà moitié des jeux qu'elle
donnait alors des filles de filles
bah ouais des fois j'y peux rien je
compte
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé je sais pas ce qui m'a
pris j'ai pété un plomb je suis trop con
je suis je suis vraiment le dernier des
coûts et ça je crois que j'ai vomi et
terminé son raz du sol alors tous de la
voiture
je t'en prie dix mois ce qui se passe et
comment ce pas je voudrais qu est ce que
tu as fait
admirer cette fois ci tu as plus
l'excusé d'être mon beau-frère de sales
ventes et surtout à malades dangereux
claude à claudia toi tu sors pas tu
restes avec maria claudia tu peux monter
devant mais tu laisses pas noël j'en ai
assez libyen barre en haut avec les
picards yves albert il faut que tu te
rendes
jetant pessamit quand michael tout
situeront devarient ça va mal finir csu
et demi mon vol dits boîtes effet albert
selon les lois de ce pays était
considéré comme innocent jusqu'à présent
mais ils sont là mais que les bus
mémoire
des solutions hiver je peux pas mieux
que ces autres je te plante est l'un des
mieux engagés texte prix vont en
souffrir mais
on va démarrer
regarder devant vous monsieur de san vou
je peux faire ça
alors ça ressemble à saint-basile de
dingue
c'est plutôt sympa avec ted friedman
et vous avez une section spéciale pour
les filles toujours tout droit l'égard
dès lors il lui il est là depuis
longtemps c'est pas beau jaune y en a un
ça va c'est une question
je croyais qu'on avait dit que j'aurais
pas de codétenus
chi
commence par te laver les mains dans
l'évier ouais moi aussi ça me fait
plaisir
j'adore ta des coûts
et
je te connais moi je te connais pas non
non non
je te connais tu oublie jamais un visage
et ben tu vois moi non plus et pourtant
tu me dis rien
c'est parce que t'es pas assez concentré
tu peux pas de souvenir d'un truc que tu
as pas bien vu
on février de l'année dernière ouais
c'est ça c'était toi l'espèce de comics
à l'identification
jamais fait l'identification
que si
c'est le jour où j'ai plongé
il voulait absolument que je sois
l'étrangleur de boston non mais tu y
croies à un type aussi gentil poids
l'étrangleur de boston
attends une minute ça y est maintenant
je me souviens franchement j'étais bien
content que la témoin s'est choisi toi
en plus le même jour en sortant du
commissariat je suis tombé sur une perle
je te raconte même pas mais sur à vie
pour toi
ah je voulais pas te manquer de respect
ou quoi mais quand même ce jour là les
charges s'était enfin ça faisait
beaucoup pour mes titres c'est pour
qui te dit comment tu as fait pour t'en
sortir
j'avais reçu pour un ticket de course
gagnant
l'alibi parfait ainsi sur deux cadeaux
mana
bat alors lequel liche point
ce que tu veux
je dois pas sur un lit
les tudors sur quoi la tuque il lévite
c'est ça
non je dors pas très souvent
quand ça m'arrive
je me mets simplement par terre
mais alors j'avais pas tort est dans une
sorte de délire bouddhiste
au
[Musique]
non trop petit et paulin
alors
t'as fait quoi exactement
pourquoi tu es ici albert dooh tu
connais mon nom j'ai de bons souvenirs
souvenirs d'accord le jour au
commissariat
tu te souviens de st un an après rhett
je vais privilégier figure toi
avant de partir du commissariat ce choix
avait une liste avec les noms de tous
les suspects qui étaient là au cas où
mon à l'ebit aurait pas tenu
s'il avait pas tenu je crois je me
serais servi de cette liste pour mettre
à juillet bordel dans la sphère ouais
bien sûr tu peux faire ça tu es encore
plus fort qu'un avocat pas les contacts
partout tu es peut-être un ancien flic
non j'ai juste quelqu'un qui réfléchit
beaucoup
sa turbine dans mon crâne
c'est toujours la même question comment
sortir de ce trou
était là pour quoi en fait
j'ai éclaté un gars
six balles dans la tête à bout portant
pourquoi t'as fait ça pourquoi six fois
pour l'achever
je lui avais déjà mis 5 coups de couteau
j'ai eu ta grand mère au téléphone
et
franchement c'est pas juste où je
voulais rester je sais oui mais c'est
comme ça
écoute moi qui suis assez clair je me
fiche de savoir si tes copines seront
déçus tu vas t'occuper de ta grand-mère
et c'est ça qui compte qu'est ce que je
veux moi ça compte pas ce que tu veux
c'est fait mais du cannabis et boire de
l'alcool et c'est bien pour ça que tu
vas aller chez sa grand mère à l'époque
maman regarde devant c'est bizarre
qu'est ce que ce type devant là on dirai
comment je respecte
wesh nos
débats
les faits comme si tu remarqué rien ces
petits mois grosse larve un pleur
pourtant salle genou j'ai dit je vous en
prie je vous en supplie ne tirez pas
vous pouvez prendre la caisse prenez
tout l'argent mais laissez-moi à
monsieur pas vite
maintenant j'ai une bonne raison de
d'éclater chez moi les mecs qui rend
peuple mérite même pas de frigo non non
arrêtés avaient été faites pas ça
munich re est vraiment pas de vrai dire
je sais quelque chose
oui
[Musique]
il a fallu qu'ils jouent au héros
moi j'étais seulement là pour la caisse
il n'était pas obligé de me faire tout
un numéro et tu l'a poignardée cinq fois
absolument
pourquoi t'as jamais tué personne toi
m'a pas vraiment non on ne peut pas dire
ça
commence a pas vraiment c'est quoi ta
[ __ ] de nuance
bien il y a eu cette cause est ce une
fois je voulais pas foncièrement lui
faire du mal seulement elle a eu
vachement peur et elle a fait une crise
cardiaque vers le tout mais raide
je te dise je t'aime bien dans ton
jantes est plutôt marrant
c'était une sorte d'accident est
pourtant souvent je me dis que si
j'avais pas débarquer comme ça derrière
elle et ben il serait peut-être encore
en mesure d'aller à la messe et enfin je
veux dire elle est tombée j'ai pas
appeler l'ambulance donc je suis
responsable il trouve coffret pour ça
non
pourquoi alors
je peux devenir très content des
chiffres un joli qu'est ce compte là
tous les hommes seraient en prison
[Musique]
john vient de coucher
j'ai entendu un bruit ce qui est très
normal on vit dans le quartier le plus
bruyant de boston allez viens plutôt
dormir
durant une voyante eu et policiers de
quoi peut tu avoir peur
je peur pour toi quand on n'est pas
ensemble
mais je peux très bien me débrouiller
tout seul gros ça tu te sens capable
d'arrêter un gain d'un mètre 80 bien sûr
ça ira vite à grands coups dans les
partis
et pendant qu'il est pliée en deux jeux
mort directe à la jugulaire exactement
comme tu m'as pris
john on est en plein milieu de la nuit
si on essayait de dormir
tentant du saint
nom john je n'ai rien entendu pour moi
tout ça c'est dans ta tête
écoute cette affaire de l'étrangleur ça
perturbe non je ne suis pas perturbé tu
ne peux pas travailler sur ces affaires
de meurtres sans être touché au fond de
toi c'est tout à fait normal c'est
humain
une femme est peut-être en train de se
faire tuer en ce moment même et je ne
peux absolument rien y faire je suis sur
cette enquête depuis deux ans et je n'ai
toujours rien je ne peux pas la résoudre
personne n'y peut
mais je ne suis pas personne chéri
depuis le début de cette affaire tu en
as résolu dix autres là c'est différent
mais en quoi
c'est le plus gros dossier qu'on ait
jamais eue c'est carrément plus énorme
que jack l'éventreur
quoi
qu'est ce qui t'arrive j'en ai assez
c'est tout je vais dormir sur le canapé
mais pourquoi tu ne t'en rends peut-être
pas compte mais tu me fais peur john
[Musique]
c'est vraiment nécessaire que vous
restiez collé derrière moi c'est pour
votre sécurité monsieur
ça t'arrive de jouer sans tricher vous
avez de la visite de salvo
grand jeu les guertin et comme tu veux
parler arrange les au quai malbert je te
présente monsieur whitmore
monsieur whitmore j'aimerais vous
présenter un homme qui est en plus
d'être déjà célèbre dans le monde entier
se préparent à être bientôt très riche
mon ami albert de salvo
ça me fait rudement plaisir de vous
rencontrer mais aussi huit morts franck
m'a beaucoup parlé de vous
et c'est lui l'étrangleur de boston en
chair et en os devant vous monsieur
c'est pas génial ça
je trouve pas
mais bon
allez m'expliquer ce serait bien si
vous savez sûrement que cette ville a
dépensé des millions de dollars pour
vous retrouver le district attorney a
même créé une force spéciale dont le
seul objectif est de vous coincez à
trois ans qu'il vous cherche sans avoir
rien trouvé comment fait-on pour être
aussi insaisissable
c'est simple
albert est comme un chat il peut entrer
et sortir de n'importe quel appartement
de boston sans élevé
jamais témoin
jamais
alors pourquoi oui
un homme avec une famille une femme des
enfants un chien un petit jardin à la et
bien taillée
personne ne vous aurais jamais suspecté
eh bien disons que je vois ça comme
comme un changement de carrière
un changement de carrière écoutez
monsieur 8 mars
on est bien
sous le coup de la confidentialité on
est d'accord écoute tu connais la
musique tout ce que tu diras dans cette
pièce restera dans cette pièce c'est pas
moi qui décide c'est la loi alors ouais
c'est bien confidentiel bien parce qu'en
fait
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
prime est celle offerte par whitfield
dix mille dollars pour chaque info
valable même par meurtre
ce qui veut dire un total de 100 mille
dollars
une idée c'est que j'en parle à franck
franck va en parler aux flics il touche
la récompense est innoncent la partage à
deux et vous vous serez à la une de
l'actualité une vedette
après toute publicité est bonne à
prendre
des clients comme celui-là vous en aurez
pas d'eux dans une vie ça va faire un
bruit énorme les gens vont vouloir le
crucifix sur place la presse va se faire
un plaisir de creuser une tombe sous ses
pieds
mais il ya un truc
mais c'est quoi
c'est que vous aller plaider la folie
quoi pour l'union pour moi écoutez je
vais finir ma vie en temps mais si on
arrive à faire passer à la folie je suis
au moins sûr de pas me faire exécuter et
peut-être que je finirais dans un
hôpital sympa mais plus intéressant
c'est que nos familles profiteront de
l'argent
d'accord je le ferai
génial bravo monsieur si vous aviez
c'est parfait elle vraiment merci
monsieur mercy bay aura une condition
aurait dit tout si vous touchez cette
récompense on divise cette somme entre
nous en trois par yann c'est quoi cette
histoire on n'a jamais parlé de ça mais
attends albert attend monsieur whitmore
franck sur cette affaire je toucherai
rien on m'a mis là d'office et
franchement si tu veux m'intéressait
c'est le moins que tu puisses faire on
n'a même pas l'argent vous fait déjà pas
mais attendez on n'a pas fini écoute
même comme celle temps restera
et surtout il faut bien que tu
comprennes que sans lui on voit rien
tu veux arrêter maintenant alors que
notre plan se concrétise albert on peut
pas faire machine arrière
amplifié a que lui qui peut sauver de la
chaise électrique
savez
monsieur de salvo je crois que vous vous
rendez pas bien compte de ce qu'elle
public l'adorent pense véritablement de
vin
qui veulent pas seulement vous voir
crier sur la chaise électrique ils
veulent d'abord vous mettre en pièces
ils veulent vous voir à terre vous
traîner jusqu'à un lampadaire vous y
suspendre et vous éviscéré comme un porc
c'est ça qu'ils veulent nous faire là
dehors
mais je peux aussi prendre les choses en
main et faire en sorte que vous ayez une
vie longue et confortable
monsieur huit morts il faut que vous
compreniez tout ça je le fais pour mes
doigts et pour ma femme pour personne
d'autre de nous trois mois qui converse
et ablement à risque je suis le seul à
jouer ma propre
hindi callas écoute
ça va bien se passer
et on n'a pas trop le choix toute façon
on peut pas revenir en arrière
maintenant tu as plus qu'une seule chose
à faire c'est de laisser monsieur
whitmore d'organiser une bonne petite
retraite
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'ils auraient pas
droit un peu d'argent je te rappelle que
je le connais
et je sais que c'est un bosseur il
jouera toujours la meilleure carte
quelle qu'elle soit pour te sortir de la
merde
choisi je te comprends
mais là vous réagir
il temps joue contre toi
alors
est-ce qu'on a marché
d'accord
ok faut qu on se tient au courant
messieurs
tu as fait le bon choix s'ils gardent
inspecteurs mart scène désolé vous
connaissez albert de salvo oui c'est un
suiveur notoire également
exhibitionniste pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il
ya
maquoy vas-y crache le morceau eh bien
il vient d'avouer qu'il était
l'étrangleur de boston il a avoué quoi
c'était lui l'étrangleur et comme il est
déjà coffret pour autre chose et va ça y
est on peut dire que c'est fini terminé
l'étrangleur
je pensais que ça vous ferait plaisir de
l'apprendre je me disais que que ça vous
rendrait fou de joie un peu comme les
collègues en bas qui font la fête et ce
congratule à tour de bras renault une
vraie nouba
[Musique]
si j'étais vous je descendrai profiter
de ça
oui
oui je vais descendre et d'ailleurs je
compte bien vous offrir aux verts donnez
moi juste cinq minutes oui bien sûr
[Musique]
je suis vraiment content que vous soyez
venu j'aimerais vous présenter un très
bon ami il s'appelle franck francs 15
orient et franck je te présente mon
frère michael et son épouse ma belle
soeur sandra ravi de vous connaître
et ravi de le connaître
on n'est pas censé être en famille ça va
je t'assure frank fait partie de la
famille allait il y revient à sylvain
alors j'y comprends rien albert
et franchement je sais pas quoi de dire
y'a rien à dire à part que j'ai fait des
conneries des conneries albert tu
assassines des femmes tu appelle ça des
conneries
albert on n'arrive même pas à comprendre
comment c'est seulement possible qu'avec
tu avais des problèmes avec les filles
mais de là à commettre des meurtres
bah écoutez vous savez pas forcément
tout cette histoire est bien plus
compliquée qu'il n'y paraît je suis loin
d'avoir tout dit mais il ya quand même
une chose qui est sûr c'est qu'avec ça
je vais bientôt me faire un gros paquet
de fric je suis les jeunes célébrités
nom albert tu n'a rien d'une célébrité
tu n'es pas un chanteur à la mode tu as
tueur en série écoute ça va je sais bien
qu'on n'est pas souvent d'accord sur
grand chose mais là c'est de la logique
ce qui compte c'est de devenir sellem
peu importe comment non non ça je
comprends pas
pour commencer il ya la prime que franck
va récupérer pour nous après ça les
interview à la télé et puis les contrats
signés pour les livres et même pour des
films d'alain je t'assure c'est pas des
conneries il prépare déjà un film sur
moi hollywood et devine qui va me jouer
ni curtis en concert c'est démentiel tu
massacre des femmes et une voix devenir
vedette de cinéma
écoutez dans tous les cas je vais passer
le reste de ma vie à l'ombre pour
d'autres crimes alors bon je peux bien
avoir droit à un compromis le planquer
imaginer franck est tout à fait
raisonnable et asie expliqué
eh bien
on a décidé avec notre avocat maître
stuart whitmore que dans cette affaire
il plaiderait la folie
monsieur whitmore a passé un marché avec
la tournée générale pour garantir à
albert que ce qu'il dira sur
l'étrangleur ne servira pas contre lui
en plus de ça et la presse a déjà fait
son procès dont en large alors à quoi
bon convoqué un jury
ils vont se contenter de le juger pour
exhibitionnisme non mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire vous êtes avocat vous
faites du droit vous parlez au nom de
qui là je comprends pas il parle en mon
nom à moi michael si tu veux comprendre
commence par l'écouté asie
comme je vous le disais mettre huit
morts va démontrer au jury qu'albert est
aliéné celle d'harnes
et donc au lieu d'aller à walpole il
sera envoyé dans une sorte de country
club aux frais de l'état
moi ça me va et je demande pas mieux
michael j'en ai assez entendue comme ça
et ça ne m'intéresse pas
comment tu peux faire ça albert août a
appris à tricher comme ça michael si une
chance demain tout le monde connaîtra le
nom d' albert de salvo c'est bien pour
ça que maman s'est battu mais pour qu'on
soit reconnue non non c'est pas du tout
à ça qu'elle pensait
je préfère encore être plombier jusqu'à
la fin de mes jours que me retrouver une
seule minute dans la mer doute ai je
t'aime frère je suis navré de voir
toutes les semaines je te promets même
que la prochaine fois je tape au retrait
des cartes et on pourra taper le carton
bonne idée on se fera une boîte comme au
bon vieux temps ciao michael
ça va c'est cool
tu as fait le bon choix
toute façon il peut pas comprendre
c'est qu'un 'plan b'
ici parce que tu subis
[Musique]
tu as raison frac
et c'est parce que j'ai subi
elle est au complet absolument tout y'a
pas un détail qui manquent on pourrait
presque croire que c'est elle qui a tué
ces gens tête elle dit qu'il y avait un
paquet de cigarettes presque vide juste
en dessous du lit et qu'ils étaient
trois et oui c'est très bien ça c'est
exactement le genre de détails qu'il
faut qu'on sache il faut qu'on
connaissait tant qu'être muc n'importe
qui du secteu m'en tiens là elle
expliqué rga a été retrouvé dans une
robe de chambre de couleur bleu avec des
motifs à fleurs mais pas des fleurs
imprimées des fleurs cousue et ça c'est
bon à savoir
[Musique]
tu fais quoi et là il faut que je
regarde l'image ya comme ça qu'elle
saint-prime bravo mon esprit [ __ ] mais
de quoi est ce que tu parles tu sais
bien j'ai une mémoire photographique et
l'orge faudra vie mais tu m'avais jamais
dit que tu savais faire ça c'est
essentiel si comme une bonne blague
belge concept au monde en aval de
mémoire visé
tu te rends compte que pour nous c'est
un don du ciel c'est ce qui pouvait nous
arriver mieux pourquoi est elle
réfléchit pas à regarder les images
libéralisme
c'est pas bien mais elle fait aussi tu
vas tout connaître par coeur mis en
place et ça en même temps je sais pas
s'il compte officialiser tout pose pas
de questions regardez tous ces
normes
maintenant regardez là
[Musique]
d'accord suivante s il veut où on peut
aller plus vite un bâton html par la
suite la taille est un
[Musique]
monsieur de salle enfin je vous rends
compte je dois dire que ça me fait un
drôle d'effet de parler à quelqu'un
d'aussi célèbre que vous avance à la
personne la plus célèbre que j'ai
rencontrés c'était me sohio 1957
or on n'avait pas parlé de détecteur de
mensonges du calme albert ce n'est qu un
magnétophone il va nous servir à
enregistrer votre confession pour la
reporter dans le dossier
il n'y pas que j'ai un problème avec ces
appareils mais je préfère quand même
qu'on en parle avant ne vous inquiétez
pas nous avons tous des secrets
mais les seuls qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui sont ceux de votre
confession
vous êtes prêts
on voit le feu
est bien pour commencer monsieur de
salvo a appelé moi albert et j'aimerais
autant qu'on commence du bon pied je
suis on peut plus d'accord
albert
pouvez vous me dire comment vous avez
procédé avec un assesseur bien je
l'avais repéré parce qu'elle m'avait 10
ont tapé dans l'oeil et à partir de là
j'ai fait comme des billets vous avez
tapé dans l'oeil mais anas leseur était
une femme de 55 ans
ouais je sais mais ça l'empêché pas
d'être très attrayante pour son âge
je suis rentrée chez elle
je vais aller me planquer dans un des
placards et là j'ai attendu qu'elle
arrive d'habitude je me planque plutôt
dans la chambre mais là j'étais au rez
de chaussée je l' ai entendu arriver
lvl avait un gros sac avec elle un sac
de chez game boys vraiment ça quand même
c'est curieux parce que le dossier
stipule bien qu'il s'agissait d'un sac
de courses ouais
ouais et alors c'est pas incompatibles
c'était un sac bulls avec dedans il y
avait des gens la viande du lait des
trucs comme ça
james tu as montré
donc je suis resté là un moment à la
regarder ranger ses 100 sacs de courses
dans la cuisine tout ça depuis le bout
du couloir et vous vous souvenez bien
que vous l'avez assassiné dans la
chambre
attendez on parle bien d'un assesseur
absolument
effectivement un peu plus tard elle est
monté dans sa chambre je les rejoindre
sans qu'elle s'en rende compte je suis
en mode invisible il ya aucun moyen de
me surprendre
[Musique]
james
[Rires]
[Musique]
et dites-moi le bas dont vous vous êtes
servi pour l'étrangler où l'avez-vous
trouvé exactement
attendais et je vois que vous essayez de
me piéger monsieur dizaine seulement ce
meurtre là il se trouve que je m'en
souviens très bien en fait j'ai enroulé
la ceinture de sa robe autour de sa
gorge et j'ai tiré d'un coup sec pour
qu'elle arrête de crier seulement bon
elle se débattait elle se débattait même
tellement fort qu après coup j'ai eu des
marques alors bon il fallait bien que je
l'art est donc j'ai tiré plus fort et il
aime bien ça fait déjà beaucoup
d'informations
seulement maintenant il va falloir qu'on
revienne sur tout ça juste pour être sûr
que tout est cohérent je veux dire on a
déjà tout seulement vous connaissez des
juges mais un s'il le faut je vous
écoute
nous disions donc
pour revenir un peu en arrière le jour
vous avez agressé anna cela vous êtes
d'abord caché dans le placard du
rez-de-chaussée ce n'est qu'ensuite que
vous êtes montés dans la chambre pour
l'agression proprement dit c'est bien
saint albert mais c'est exactement ce
qui s'est passé
écoute
je suis désolé albert
des séries
c'est tout ce que vous avez à me dire
c'est ça qui me consolera quand je serai
à hualpen
la procédure d'appel est d'ores et déjà
en route
vous avez vu ces jurés
vous avez vu leur visage
tous ces bons chrétiens
ils voulaient ma peau ils veulent me
voir crier
j'ai finir sur la chaise nom albert
c'est en appel
rien de plus à faire
reste plus qu'à attendre
attendre que cette hystérie stas
c'est qu'une question de temps
ah ouais
c'est ça votre opinion professionnels
walpole tu seras avec franck france va
partir sur la chaise électrique et vous
le savez
ça aussi c'est un appel
écoute albert tu t'en sors tu quand même
pas si mal tu vas te faire pas mal de
pognon qui va avoir ton livre et même
ton film tout ça ça tient encore je vais
être à walpole bordel je vais être au
milieu de centaines de cas qui veulent
ma peau ils me tueront dès mon arrivée
les quotas berre il faudrait pas que tu
oublies que cette merde c'est le
résultat des actes pas des miens à mon
niveau j'ai fait tout ce qui était en
mon pouvoir pour t'aider absolument tout
non non j'ai besoin de savoir si tu veux
que je me batte pour que cet appel
aboutissent
mais j'en sais rien c'est encore je
savais ce que franck en pense quoi
énerver vous voulez froc pour une fois
c'est moi le temps avant qu'un bordel
faut un peu plus rien pour toi
il faut que tu comprennes
que cet appel c'est ta dernière chance
c'est même la seule que tu es d'être
transféré dans une clinique et ça c'est
bien ce que tu veux non
ouais
vous avez raison
cet appel ça va prendre du temps et
d'ici que ça aboutisse les gens
penseront l étrangleur
il faudra qu'on en oublie un peu ça
ouais
c'est bien ça
reste simplement discret sans te faire
marcher dessus
et dans quelques mois on sera sur de
nouvelles bases
et là tu sera transférée
si ça peut aller
je te file un peu de liquide pour les
frais courants
42 la recette de ram
ça paiera même pas mon [ __ ] cercueil
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui qu'albert henry le
seul vous cet homme de 35 ans qui
prétend avoir été l'étrangleur de boston
a été condamné à perpétuité pour vol à
main armée l'exhibitionnisme et quatre
agressions sur des femmes son avocat
maître stuart whitmore qui aura prêté
jusqu où ils responsabilité de son
client a déclaré à la presse je cite le
massachusetts vient de brûler une
nouvelle sorcière mais ce n'est pas la
faute du jury c'est celle de la loi
selon l'argumentation de la défense de
seul vous souffrirait de graves troubles
schizophréniques et bien que les 13
meurtres commis à boston entre 62 et 64
n'ai pas eu de rapport direct avec ce
procès ils ont toutefois été
instrumentalisé par la défense vient
ainsi cherché à démontrer que l'auteur
de tels actes ne pouvait être que fou
mais la cour a refusé de prendre en
compte les témoignages liés à la ferté
l'étrangleur c'est donc en tant qu'homme
responsable que cet ancien champion de
boxe est en service dans la police
militaire en allemagne à écouter le
président du jury monsieur hunter rolly
analystes financiers de concorde le
déclarer coupable des dix accusations
formulées contre lui il aura donc fallu
trois heures
je te jure je peux plus je peux vraiment
plus je peux pas continuer comme ça il
faut que ça s'arrête
six ans c'est déjà beaucoup et puis et
puis j'ai changé je suis plus le même
qu'avant je travaille à l'infirmerie je
m'occupe des personnes âgées et j'ai
plus touché à une goutte d'alcool depuis
bridgewater quelle différence c'est vrai
si je leur disais la vérité quelle
différence après si je leur disais que
je suis pas l'étrangleur j'ai jamais été
l'étrangleur
la célébrité je m'en fiche de toute
façon ça m'a jamais rien rapporté même
pas tant l'art même pas même pas un
centime mais le plus important
si je parle c'est peut-être que que ma
famille il faudra bien droit voire
nom albert
tu dois en parler à personne
et ça jusqu'à la fin de ta vie
mais pourquoi franck pourquoi quelques
différences a pas faire tu dois le faire
parce que je te le demande
je veux pas replonger
si tu parles je serai impliqué et ça je
veux pas tu vois ça sert à rien d'aller
remuer le passé
pour moi c'est terminé
et c'est très bien comme ça
tu parles comme s'il y avait un truc que
tu voulais pas que je sache est ce que
tu me cache quelque chose
je veux que tu fermes ta gueule autres
mangent toujours que je te la pètes en
deux contre un mur
je suis sûr que tu me cache des trucs
en fait ça fait des années que je te
fais plus confiance
et j'ai plus rien à dire
j'ai assez parlé comme ça
tu peux penser ce que tu veux toute
façon c'est plus mon problème
tu te rends compte que tu as fait
le temps joue contre toi
j'ai besoin du 3
août assure je suis plus le même
qu'avant
gardiens
allô docteurs à rennes c'est moi albert
albert de salvo et bien si je
m'attendais à voir de vos nouvelles
comment ça va pour vous
et bien en fait plutôt pas mal walpole
n'est pas si terrible que ça finalement
ah je me suis fait mon petit trouve j'en
suis ravi pour vous albert et ça me fait
bien plaisir de vous entendre seulement
pourquoi pourquoi m'appeler moi il y à
quelque chose dont j'ai besoin de parler
oui mais il ya de très bon psychiatre
paul non là c'est différent
ce que je veux c'est dire la vérité au
sujet de l'étrangleur de boston
la vérité
d'accord vous avez fait le bon choix
mais on peut pas parler de ça au
téléphone
je vais faire en sorte qu'on puisse se
voir demain à 9 heures dans une salle de
thérapie privé là on pourra parler
way serait super
merci docteur merci du fond du coeur
[Musique]
quoi qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que
vous voulez et [ __ ] question vous
faites mine qu'est ce que vous voulez
[Musique]
de talence
c'est bon vous pouvez l'emmener
[Musique]
le corps d'albert de salvo connu pour
avoir été l'étrangleur de boston a été
retrouvé ce matin poignardé à mort à la
prison d'état de walpole selon les
autorités pénitentiaires
le corps était allongé par terre à
l'intérieur de la cellule qu'il occupait
dans le quartier médical quartier dans
lequel elle travaillait par ailleurs
bien que les circonstances exactes de
cet assassinat n'est pas été déterminée
le district attorney du comté de norfolk
annoncé qu'un suspect est interrogé en
ce moment même bien que de salvo et
confessé il ya plusieurs années de cela
en 2001 la dernière victime de
l'étrangleur fut exhumé par la police
scientifique afin de rechercher
d'éventuels fragments qui aurait pu
contenir l'adn de l'assassin des traces
adn provenant de deux individus
différents furent découverts sous ses
ongles et sur ses sous vêtements mais
aucun de ces deux individus n'étaient
albert de salvo
la sphère de l'étrangleur de boston n'a
jamais été élucidé et personne n'a
jamais été jugé pour ces meurtres à ce
jour l'enquêté toujours ouverte